the square it currently uh occupies so
still somewhere to be done but i think
magnus
should be able to win this game okay
and black just waits with the pawn it's
kind of like both sides are stuck and
both sides want the opponent to
have the move and magnus now again
offering this trade
he's trying to fix black's pawn on that
square so the knight can now probably
come in at some point at least and
capture uh that backwards pawner blacks
but
is that saying that uh you know chess is
90
tactics and even if you get an ending
like this which you know people might
assume is positional
it often comes down just to you have to
calculate so carefully in any position
so that's why calculation is is very
important uh even if you want to be a
positional player you have to be able to
calculate so well and do we have a
result now maybe i think yeah i think
we're about to see a result if no we do
see a result this was actually i was
going to say a position we called
zugswang black cannot make a move
without sacrificing something or losing
some